Opposers, the fight is back.
And the stakes
are higher than ever,
because a hundred percent
of 50% of the population
is at risk
of total eradication...
of their identity.
I'm talking about men.
An overwhelming six states
now have female governors,
which means only 44 states
stand between us
and a complete "fempire."
It's time to suit up for battle,
because-- wardrobe, please...
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
...there's a war on men!
Something ominous is happening
to men in America...
...a war on men.
The liberals' war on men
is working.
(laughing)
...war on men...
(deep, distorted growling)
(cheering, applause)
Men...
this war is nothing new.
Women have been out to get us
from birth.
In fact, all fetuses start
as female in the womb,
until some of us brave souls
fight our way to a penis.
And what's worse,
just because women's bodies
are tiny baby apartments,
they think they get to call
the shots on motherhood.
Battleground one: Babies.
-(military percussion plays)
-Senator Tammy Duckworth
recently because
the first senator to give birth
while in office.
And then something
even more frightening happened.
NEWSWOMAN: Tammy Duckworth
arrived to cast a vote
with her ten-day-old daughter
by her side.
The Senate unanimously decided
last night
to allow working moms
on the Hill
to bring their newborns
to work.
Like anything else
in the Senate, though,
it wasn't without
some bellyaching.
Senator Orrin Hatch even asking
and telling the A.P.,
"But what if there are ten
babies on the Senate floor?"
Exactly.
Hatch knows babies are loud,
disruptive and in diapers.
And that's totally his thing.
(laughter)
And sure, there's only one
female senator under 50,
but women are sneaky.
They're always creeping up
behind you to say, "It's yours."
(laughter)
Don't be fooled.
This newborn fever
is just the latest way
women have stripped men
of their basic liberties.
Did you know that
as recently as 2009
the Senate used to have
a "men's only" pool.
Of course they did.
Where else was Mitch McConnell
supposed to birth his eggs?
-(laughter)
-And...
in 2013, a record number
of women invaded the Senate
and then suddenly, months later,
the Senate floor bathrooms
had to be expanded for women.
These women are capturing
our porcelain thrones.
Women just want everything
men have: our money, our power,
our convenient bowel movements.
This is a pissing contest
that we will win,
because we do it standing.
And that's not all.
Men are being attacked
on all fronts:
our homes, our works,
even our happy places.
Specifically,
the happiest place on earth.
Battleground number two:
Disney World.
(military percussion plays)
The Pirates of the Caribbean
ride is ground zero
for the feminist assault,
where crybabies are saying
outrageous things,
like, auctioning off brides
at a family theme park
is problematic.
This attraction,
the Pirates of the Caribbean,
-Oh, God.
-it's been there for 50 years.
It was originally
a bride auction.
They've decided that this
is too controversial,
and it's a Me Too moment.
Maybe the little hula girls
at the Small World,
-they need to come out as well.
-Oh, no, no.
I got stuck on that ride,
It's a Small World.
I was stuck in there
for, like, 45 minutes.
Of course,
Laura Ingraham got stuck
on the "Small World" ride,
because every hero
has an origin story.
And you know what?
Getting trapped
in a globalist hellscape
of multicultural animatronics
is Laura's.
Now, the removal
of the wench auction
from the
Pirates of the Caribbean ride
sets a dangerous precedent
to men
because it's different.
Disney and its rides teach boys
to become men.
If little boys can't look
at a bunch
of seafaring murder pimps
and think,
"That's what I want to be
when I grow up,"
what do they have left?
Representation matters.
And, look,
I know I'm right here,
because the men who are upset
by this change
are the most well-adjusted
people in America:
adults who go to Disney World.
But man magic isn't
the only ground we've lost
in the war on men.
They're also renovating the
fields of math and science,
which brings me to our
final battleground: STEM.
It stands for science,
technology,
engineering, and math.
Though it might as well
stand for
"stealing to eliminate men."
Because women are taking
our math and science jobs.
For years,
I thought it was because
we summoned women
on our calculators.
But...
it turns out
there's another reason.
TV REPORTER: The Scully effect:
Women who regularly watch
or watched The X-Files are 50%
more likely to work
in science, technology,
engineering or math,
compared to women
who haven't been fans.
Nearly two-thirds of women
in those fields
say Agent Scully served as
a role model for them.
How dare they?
Math is our thing.
Two-thirds of these women
said Scully was a role model,
but what about the other half?
(laughter)
Because of the XX-Files,
a whole generation of women
are storming our labs
and taking our jobs.
And if this show inspired them,
who knows what other
strong female characters
have activated women.
There might be a horde
of warrior princesses
out there ready to attack,
or an army of women
just waiting to explain it all.
It's unbelievable.
Men are the ones
who explain things.
Explaining things to people
is the last thing men have left.
Okay, okay.
Let me explain it to you.
You see, Opposers,
men, we are under attack.
We need to make Disney
less "family"
and more "manly."
Because we've lost the battle
of Space Mountain,
but we need to counterstrike
until Disney's Epcot Center
has two balls, as God intended.
And we need to get back to the
position where the only time
a man has to deal
with an infant at work
is when he's delivering it
with his right hand
and holding a lit cigarette
in his left.
Men, get in your battle stance,
which takes up approximately
three seats on the subway.
We're going to compensate
for the ground we've lost.
In fact, we'll overcompensate
until we feel secure again.